well let's look back at the history of
the idea of the record in my book sound
unbound we traced the guy who have
actually came up with the main concept
for the graphic design of the record
cover sleeve his name's alex stein was
and one of the things in my book that we
really tried to figure out was the
revolution in graphic design that
occurred when people put images on album
covers now if you think about the 20th
century and the idea of visual visual
vocabulary the album occupies a really
important space in the cultural
landscape and above all try this
experiment one day going to record store
and just try and guess what the music
sounds like by looking at the album
cover you'll get this kind of
psychological relationship to the
imagery of the music but that idea is
translated to iPhone apps is translated
to the small you know kind of icons on
your computer you name it the idea of a
visual icon that gives you a sense of
information very quickly and that you
can easily just say that's what the
style is that's something that I think
record coverage sleeves really led
towards but at the same time the album
as we know it didn't come into being
until mainly after the Second World War
because record labels realized they'd be
able to make a lot more money putting
all the singles of an artist unto one
album and selling the whole album as a
kind of a concept so by the time the
sixties rolled in that became a huge art
form in its own right with the bands
like The Beatles and The Rolling Stones
and Hendrix to total concept albums same
thing with Pink Floyd now if you
fast-forward to the 70s and Grandmaster
Flash Afrika Bambaataa DJ Kool Herc
Grandmaster Caz all these guys that were
essentially like the DNA of what we're
doing now one of the main thing that
differentiates them from artists before
is that they made albums based on the
fact that they didn't care about the
band as in a kind of thing in its own
right they cared about manipulating the
recording and that became the album
usually bands would make a song to
record for an album but what happens
with the DJ as you say well the album is
everything we need thanks band you can
go away no you know you don't really
need the band or the singer-songwriter
in the same way so you look at
everything as part of your palate when
you think about a composer you know like
Vagner or PA blue LEDs or something like
that most of the issues of composer is
working with their butt
discreet notated music that someone else
will play but if i take that person and
play them as a record i'm becoming not
only a conductor and composer of collage
but at the same time i'm looking at a
whole layer of what goes into copyright
law who owns those memories who owns the
way that that sound gets remixed and
transform and above all how much fun it
is to actually just mess with other
people's stuff it's so yeah i like i
like the idea of it it's a trickster
motif you know like you're you're kind
of just messing around with people's
memories of songs
I tend to find that myths of the near
future give people the ability to really
kind of explore the present so say for
example if you look at William Gibson
and his book Neuromancer or if you look
at jg ballard or samuel Delaney those
are probably three of my favorite
writers in that genre all of them
project slightly to the near future as a
way of talking about the current moment
and I think science fiction and sound is
a really interesting thing you might as
well think of it as sonic fiction when
you're coming up with different ways of
getting old memories to transform your
scratching you're doing all this kind of
sampling what ends up happening is that
you're becoming a kind of writer with
sound in fact if you look at the root
word of phonograph it just means
phonetics of graphology phonograph
writing with sound so graphology you
know graffiti same root word phone etics
you know speech all this kind of stuff
phonograph simple but when you unpack
the meaning it actually kind of expands
out and that's what I was going for my
book sound unbound we should try and get
people to figure out how do we unpack
some of the meetings that go into these
kinds of sonically coded landscapes so
yeah science fiction or sonic fiction I
kind of like punting on that